and knowing how to respond in an active
shooter situation is really critical no
matter where you are today victoria saha
spoke with a retired henderson police
officer who would often teach
life-saving tips to local students
what we learned today is that if there's
an active shooter near and there's no
way for you to run you need to hide turn
off all the lights but don't go hiding
under your desk because that still makes
you an open target instead find some
furniture that you can conceal yourself
with it's a situation no one expects to
be in but david comey a retired nypd and
henderson police officer says you must
always be prepared for the unexpected
colemeyer says if danger is near you
have three options run hide or fight if
it's too dangerous to run then work
together to make the classroom safe
someone could scream hey get the lights
turn the lights off or someone say
barricade the door i mean talking to
other students and basically
preparing or actively doing something at
the time communication is key which is
why having drills is so important the
clark county school district says each
year all staff are required to watch
multiple safety videos on how to respond
to an active shooter and drills take
place every month to prepare for real
situations
in a situation like this everyone might
be on the phone with police or texting
loved ones but we learned that you must
always put your phone on silent if
you're trying to hide your location
victoria saha live local now